ich - mein
die Familie – die Familien
der Opa – die Opas
die Oma – die Omas
tot
Ich bin Martin.
Das ist meine Familie.
Mein Opa heißt Hans.
Meine Oma ist schon lange tot.
die Eltern (pl.)
beide
der Vater – die Väter
die Geschwister (pl.)
Meine Eltern arbeiten beide noch.
Mein Vater verkauft Bücher.
Meine Mutter ist Lehrerin.
Ich habe leider keine Geschwister.
und
die Tochter – die Töchter
der Lkw – die Lkws (Lastkraftwagen)
werden
Peter und Helmut sind meine Söhne.
Das ist meine Tochter Katharina.
Sie will Lkw-Fahrerin werden.
der Deutsche – die Deutsche – die Deutschen
der Schweizer – die Schweizerin
– die Schweizer/Schweizerinnen
der Türke – die Türkin – die Türken/die Türkinnen
Wir sind alle Schweizer, außer meiner Frau.
Sie ist Türkin.
der Samstag
der Sonntag
Jeden Sonntag essen wir bei meinen Eltern.
gut
der Appetit
der Saft
gleich
Guten Appetit!
Möchtest du einen Apfel- oder Orangensaft?
Das ist mir gleich.
geben
er – ihm (Dativ)
der Salat
das Salz
Kannst du mir bitte das Messer geben?
Gib ihm bitte das Messer.
Wie schmeckt dir der Salat?
Ich finde ihn gut.
Kann ich bitte das Salz haben?
Hier ist es.
der Schinken – die Schinken
brauchen
schmecken
wunderbar
Ich möchte gern ein Schinkenbrot.
Ich mache dir eins.
Brauchst du den Pfeffer noch?
Nein.
Wie schmeckt das Essen?
Es schmeckt wunderbar.
das Zimmer – die Zimmer
breit
Die Zimmer sind groß.
Ja. Und die Garage ist breit genug.
die Möbel (pl.)
das Sofa
das Bett – die Betten
Sind die Möbel neu?
Nur das Sofa. Der Rest nicht.
Und wir brauchen noch ein Kinderbett.
der Anschluss
mieten
Hat das Haus einen Telefonanschluss?
Ja.
Dann möchte ich dieses Haus mieten.
der Beruf – die Berufe
die Hausfrau/der Hausmann
die Maschine – die Maschinen
machen
die Lösung – die Lösungen
Herr und Frau Schmidt, was sind Ihre Berufe?
Ich bin Ökonomin.
Er ist Hausmann.
Er wäscht, kocht und kauft ein.
Es gibt hier aber keine Waschmaschine.
Das macht nichts.
Wir können eine Waschmaschine kaufen.
Das ist eine gute Lösung.